history ladies and gentlemen history was
made in the Senate today history yeah
thanks to eight yeah I know that you
don't know what I'm talking about so I'm
gonna continue people just like whatever
what's a Senate yeah
what's the Senate yeah no this is big
thanks to a rule change babies are now
allowed on the US Senate floor yeah yeah
in the spirit of the new rules today in
the Senate Orrin Hatch had his diaper
changed
we know that was that a nice start yeah
that's the kind of show it's gonna be so
just prepare for that now there's
lettuce president Trump's new nominee to
head NASA is a Republican congressman
with no science background or as that's
called in the Trump administration
overqualified thank you
it sounded like we were in a water park
just a second ago
I didn't setup to the joke then there
was a giant splash at the end right
yesterday Patriots tight end Rob
Gronkowski bought a stake in a kentucky
derby race horse that was named after
him yeah not cool yeah yeah the
million-dollar animal bred for its
ability to run fast says he's excited to
own a share in a horse
I don't know what that reaction meant it
was like oh well it lines up nicely
camping at Coachella has been delayed
this weekend because of high winds Wow
then someone realized they just forgot
to turn off Beyonce's wind machine this
weekend is the 80th birthday of Superman
pretty cool yeah yeah now that he's 80
Superman is rendered helpless by
kryptonite and his email password we're
getting through this negotiation I do
this for tax reasons it's a legal thing
negotiations to buy the company that
makes adderall ended today without a
deal yes meanwhile talks to buy the
maker of cialis lasted over four hours
so they had to call a doctor
does of the erection you know that was
for me
[Music]
you